charles sobhraj dit le serpent arrêté à
bombay par la police indienne sobre h
qui est de nationalité française est
accusée de 15 meurtres commis en général
contre des routards ou contre des
touristes sur les routes d'asie
il s'était enfui le 16 mars dernier
d'une prison de new delhi en inde déjà
les policiers indiens lui avait tendu un
piège aujourd'hui il est tombé dedans
alors sur la personnalité de celui qu'on
appelle le land rue de l'asie du sud est
voici les précisions de frédéric est le
serpent c'est lui charles sobhraj né
d'un père indien et d'une mère française
d'origine vietnamienne
à 42 ans il a déjà une longue carrière
de grands criminels derrière lui il est
accusé d'avoir commis une quinzaine de
meurtre dans une dizaine de pays de
l'asie du sud-est en thaïlande notamment
généralement six victimes sont des
touristes qu'il a réussi à mettre en
confiance avant de les tuer parfois
d'horribles façon puis de les dépouiller
de leurs papiers et de leur argent pour
parvenir à ses fins charles sobhraj
utilise deux armes redoutables son
intelligence elle est diabolique et
surtout son charme
le metteur en scène français yves
boisset a d'ailleurs pu le vérifier en
le rencontrant il y a quelques années à
bangkok en thaïlande à l'occasion la
préparation de l'un de ses films c'est
est indiscutablement un personnage
extrêmement fascinant par son charme il
était il est très beau très cultivé et
d'une extrême extrême intelligence mais
vous savez avec tout d'un coup cette
espèce de fêlure qui fait que tout d'un
coup on se rendait compte que quelque
chose comme les packs y avait quelque
chose de bizarre de casser en lui et qui
lui donnait en même temps à côté un peu
inquiétant mais qui d'une certaine
manière pouvait faire partie aussi de
son charme
parce que je crois que le personnage est
complètement indissociables d'un charme
proche de la fascination c'est pas par
hasard qu'on l'appelait dans toute
l'asie du sud est le serpent deux livres
à succès ont déjà été consacrés à ce
véritable ennemi public devenu d'autant
plus célèbres qu'à chaque fois il est
parvenu à s'évader de sa prison reste à
savoir maintenant s'il sera extradé vers
la thaïlande où là il risque la peine de
mort la nuit prochaine pardon arrive en
france un homme qui a passé près de
vingt ans dans les prisons indiennes
sous le coup d'une expulsion charles
sobhraj est une personnalité très
controversée et est impliqué dans
plusieurs affaires de meurtre de
touristes occidentaux dans les années 70
les explications d'antoine casubolo tout
qu'ont fait les autorités de new delhi
ont décidé de se laver les mains du cash
à sauve rage le prisonnier le plus
médiatique d'un devrait être expulsé ce
soir pour paris ce français âgé de 52
ans aura passé plus de 20 ans dans les
geôles indiennes accusé d'avoir
assassiné plusieurs touristes
occidentaux en inde mais partout en asie
et c'est d'ailleurs aux lenteurs de la
justice indienne qu'il échappe à
l'extradition en thaïlande où la peine
de mort lui était promise chasse aux
barrages a déclaré être attendu à paris
par yves rénier le comédien producteur
aurait selon lui l'intention de tourner
un film sur sa vie
mais déjà des voix s'élèvent pour que
celui que l'on surnomme le serpent ne
soit pas accueilli en héros entouré
d'une nuée de photographes et de badauds
charles sobhraj s'apprête à quitter l'un
depuis sept semaines
le serpent était dans la tente d'un
laissez-passer pour la france une
demande acceptée par le quai d'orsay
vendredi effective hier soir sobra
j'avais été remise en liberté le 17
février dernier les autorités indiennes
n'ayant pas retenu la dernière charge
qui pesait contre lui son évasion en 86
d'une des prisons de new delhi sevrage
aura passé 20 ans dans les prisons
indiennes mais pour des délits mineurs
l'homme est toujours soupçonné à 52 ans
d'une série de meurtres sur des
touristes occidentaux
condamné pour l'un d'entre eux en 78 il
avait été acquitté en appel 24 mois plus
tard
d'où sa réputation d'un serpent qui
aurait toujours glisser entre les mains
de la justice
depuis les années 70 il est vraiment
sans scrupules
il est aussi particulièrement
intelligent mais ce qui est étrange
en même temps c'est qui est un grand
charmeur après la justice thaïlandaise
et indiennes ce brave va devoir être
confronté à la justice française la saga
du serpent n'est sans doute pas terminée
lui déclare ne pas s'attendre à être
poursuivi par les autorités françaises
réponse à partir d'aujourd'hui l'avocat
jacques vergès était ponctuelle ce matin
à l'aéroport de roissy mais il ne verra
pas son client
charles sobhraj h 10 le serpent est
pourtant bien arriver très surveillée
par les policiers très attendu par les
journalistes il sera transféré à l'abri
des regards dans les locaux de la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire à nanterre
pourtant charles sobhraj est un homme
libre il a purgé sa peine 20 ans de
prison en inde
son avocat ne comprend pas il n'y a pas
de poursuites contre lui j'attends comme
je suis persuadé qu'il rapportait de
leur lâcheté et de perdre la face
pendant cette semaine ils ont refusé les
papilles au bout crève semaine ils lui
ont donné des papiers
cette fois ci ils leur tiers et à la fin
ils seront forcés de le relâcher
ce ressortissant français de 52 ans est
soupçonné d'une série de meurtres de
touristes occidentaux s'étaient en asie
dans les années 70 parmi les victimes
figurent est un jeune mosellan look
salomon à l'époque âgé de 20 ans la
famille est convaincue de la culpabilité
de sevrage mais la sphère n'a jamais été
élucidé actuellement le serpent est
interrogé sur une affaire de tentative
d'empoisonnement en inde
charles sobhraj j'ai également fait
l'objet d'une vérification d'identité
[Musique]